In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for July 11 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
St. Sephroni of Essex.
Our commandrite Sephroni Sakatov was born in Moscow in the year 1896.
He studied at the National School of Fine Arts in Moscow and took up painting as his career,
as well as endowing him richly with natural talents, God also gave him exceptional spiritual
gifts from the outset of his life.
From a young age, he assimilated the spirit of the living God of his fathers.
In his youth, he was possessed by a thirst for absolute being, and he devoted himself to
a serious consideration of the existential problems of his time and place.
His intense metaphysical quest brought him to sense painfully the tragic character of
human existence.
He came to belittle the idea that the absolute could be contained in the psychological level,
as he saw it, of the gospel commandments of love, and he strayed from the path of Christianity.
He was attracted by the theories of Eastern religions, seeing in them a logical solution
to the grievous sight of suffering and pain, and he practiced for about eight years the
transcendental meditation that is linked to their psychological delusion of an impersonal
absolute.
His return to Christianity was provoked by an awakening to the scriptural text of God's
revelation to Moses, I am that I am.
By God's grace he understood that the absolute and unoriginant being is none other than the
personal God first revealed to Moses, the same God who has in these last days spoken to
us by his only begotten Son, by Jesus Christ.
See Hebrews 1-2
From the moment of his personal meeting with him who is, Father Sephroni did not rest from
an intense striving to be initiated into the mystery of the God revealed to him, and to penetrate
the infinite dimensions of the person of Christ, in whose image man was created.
With extremely intense mourning he lamented for decades his misguided quest for the impersonal,
imaginary, absolute of the oriental religions.
He viewed his laps from Christianity as a fall like that of Adam and as a suicide on the metaphysical
plane.
In his book we shall see him as he is, which is tantamount to his spiritual autobiography,
he describes how he lived out his repentance.
In the year 1925, after a short period of studies at the St. Sirgeus Theological Institute,
he left Paris for the Holy Mountain of Athos, where he lived for 22 years.
He first settled in the monastery of St. Pantelemon, where he met and formed a close spiritual bond
with St. Syloan, 1866 through 1938.
In whose person he saw clearly portrayed the authentic dimensions of Christian life.
Father Sephirone had lived for about five years at St. Pantelemon's monastery, before he
met St. Syloan personally.
He was ordained deacon in the year 1930, and each time he came out to the sanctuary to
sense the monks, he used to feel awe and shame when he passed in front of the saint.
But he had not as yet had any occasion to speak with him.
A few years after his ordination to the deaconate, Father Sephirone was visited by a hermit, Father
Vladimir, and they spoke together on various spiritual matters.
Father Vladimir was moved to compunction by their conversation, as well as by the spiritual
atmosphere of their whole meeting, and he spontaneously addressed Father Sephirone with the question,
Father Sephirone, how can someone be saved?
At that moment, Father Sephirone was preparing tea for Father Vladimir, and he replied,
stay on the verge of despair, but when you see that you are going to fall over, draw back,
and have a cup of tea, and he handed him some tea.
This word, and above all the strong feeling which had transmitted, struck the hermit, and
he left shaken.
He went afterwards to Saint Siloan to seek advice, and check the veracity of Father
Sephirone's exhortation.
The next day, Father Sephirone was coming down the staircase from the main building of the
monastery, which had many stories, towards the central courtyard, and Saint Siloan was coming
up from the warehouse in the opposite direction.
They would normally have met outside the entrance to the main church, but Father Sephirone,
that of his habitual respect, moved aside to avoid getting in the way of the holy man.
Saint Siloan, however, also changed direction, so that they met unavoidably in front of
the re-fectory.
At that point, Saint Siloan asked Father Sephirone.
Father Sephirone did Father Vladimir visit you yesterday, and Father Sephirone, omitting all
the intermediate stages usual in conversation, replied by asking, did I make any mistake?
Likewise, going straight to the point, Saint Siloan said to him, no, but what you said was
beyond his measure.
If you like, come and see me tomorrow, and we can speak more about this.
Thus, Father Sephirone visited Saint Siloan, who told him about his own life.
He recounted the fifteen-year-long battle he had waged against evil spirits.
He confided to him the revelatory word of Christ, keep thy mind in hell, and despair not,
which marked a crucial moment in his spiritual struggle, and which was powerful enough to
save him from every diabolic temptation and purify him from proud thoughts.
This historic meeting had a definitive effect on Father Sephirone's later spiritual evolution
and on his theology.
His communications with Saint Siloan reassured Father Sephirone that he was not misguided
in the spirit of repentance, which perpetually inflamed him.
He was instructed by the saint's teaching, and because of his unwavering faith in the
Stuttites' word, he acquired stability in his ascetic life and was led to freedom from passions.
He lived out the rest of his days, both in the desert, and later in his service in the
world, testifying to the fact that only by voluntarily descending to hell, following
the pattern set by the gospel, can the believer be placed securely on the path of God and
learn the indescribable humility of Christ and be united with him.
Father Sephirone held Stuttites' Siloan in such respect and trust that in spirit he
venerated his very footsteps.
He spoke and wrote about how he considered his close contact with St. Siloan as God's
greatest gift to him.
He remained close to him until the end of the saint's life, and then, with the blessing
of his abbot and the counsel of elders of the monastery, he withdrew to the desert of
Mount Athos.
From his hermit's cell, he served as Father Confessor to the monasteries of Saint Paul, Gregorio,
Simonas Petras, Xenofontos, and to many skitties and other groups of monks.
In the year 1947, he left Athos to return to France, and in the year 1948, he published
in Russian the manuscripts entrusted to him by St. Siloan before his death, having added
some biographical information and an extensive analysis of the saint's teaching.
In the year 1959, he founded in Essex, England, the community which was to become the patriarchal
St. Pagic monastery of Saint John the Baptist, where he fell asleep in the Lord on July 11,
in the year 1993.
In spiritual terms, Father Sephroni stands out as a sign from God for his generation.
He lived out the tragedy, the anxieties, the difficulties, and the quests of the much
troubled twentieth century, and through his living example, his prayer, and his word,
he gave answers to the burning questions of his contemporaries.
Father Sephroni's laps in his youth into the impersonal theology of the Oriental religions
was transformed by the wondrous providence of God into a gift from heaven.
Although Father Sephroni had never consciously rejected Christ, he nonetheless considered
his going astray as apostasy and as a crime against the love of the God of his fathers.
This became the starting point of his unremitting deep, inconsolable repentance.
Through the grace given despair of repentance, as he himself describes it, he was liberated
from the bonds of the old man, see Ephesians 4, 22, et al.
He was unable to contemplate without passions the uncreated light of the face of Christ.
From then on, he understood the spiritual place of the human person in its divine human fullness.
He saw the two great commandments of love become the law of his whole being, the first shown
in an insatiable desire for God, and the second in prayer for the world to the point of self-forgetting
and abundant tears.
In such agonized prayer, he spent himself for decades.
Because Father Sephroni had the grace given experience unique to Christianity of the personal
or, as he preferred to say, hypostatic principle, as well as knowing from within the context
of the Indian religions, he proved an invaluable apologist for orthodox Hesicastic practice
in a challenging epoch whose spirit is syncretistic.
With persuasive and compelling authority, he succeeded in describing the difference between
the two ascetic theories, Oriental and Christian, which are as far apart as the uncreated is from
the created.
He contrasted the spiritual suicide to which transcendental meditation leads with the incomparable
life-giving experience of meeting and being united with the personal God of Scripture.
Oriental Sephroni was endowed with many gifts of the Holy Spirit.
The most impressive was the living Word of God which he grasped through prayer and carried
in his heart.
He was a man of the Word.
Every contact with him was an opening to new understanding in life, and even his most
everyday words conveyed grace to those who turned to him.
He prayed continuously and intensely for those who suffer and rejoiced more than over any
miraculous occurrences to see his Word and his prayer transform their hearts.
He struggled to diminish their pain, but above all he spent himself to his utmost in the service
of the greatest and most significant miracle of our temporal life, the union of human beings
with the spirit of the living and eternal God.
No phenomenon in the spiritual life could take him by surprise.
He had traced the whole path.
At one and the same time, both unfathomable depths and immeasurable heights were within
his reach.
As well as knowing the grace of repentance, he was familiar with the alternations that occur
in the practice of inner prayer.
He was schooled in the regenerating Word of Christ and had taken upon himself his martyric
priesthood.
He deeply loved the divine liturgy and affirmed that to celebrate it appropriately is a spiritually
fruitful prayer as his hecasm in the desert.
He used to say, to be a Christian, one must be like an artist.
Just as artists are captivated by the subjects they paint and by the desire to portray them
as perfectly as possible, so too the Christian is captivated by Christ and by a desire to attain
to his endless perfection.
I press on to make it my own because Christ Jesus has made me his own Philippians 3-12.
When Father Sephroni felt his end approaching, he said, I have said everything to God.
I have finished what I had to do.
Now I must depart.
He summoned the members of the community one by one, imparting to each his final instructions
and a personal farewell word.
Then with humility as well as boldness, he wrote a fervent letter to his all holiness, patriarch
Bartholomew, with heartfelt thanks for all the care shown towards his monastery.
As well as expressing deep gratitude, he begged the patriarch to defend the fragile work of
his hands.
Give your blessing upon the lowly sheep of my fold that this place, small, poor and insignificant,
founded upon many tears and heartfelt groaning and blood and sweat may never be forsaken
by your affectionate care and good pleasure.
He ended the letter by asking his hierarchy's blessing to depart to the longed-for light
of the risen Christ.
Father Sephroni passed away peacefully and now reposes in the Lord, but he continues through
his word and his prayers to minister for the miracle that his soul desired, the regeneration
of the faithful and their entrance richly provided for into the eternal kingdom of our Lord
and Savior, Jesus Christ, 2 Peter 1-11.
In all his books, he develops Christian anthropology in the light of St. Syloon's experience, which
he also shared, in his teaching on the person he continually portrays St. Syloon as a model.
His anthropology follows the tradition of the Church, but he develops it with a particular
emphasis and an original robustness and inspiration, which grew out of his long and exceptional
trials in the furnace of God's training.
The originality of Father Sephroni's theology lies in his interpretation of certain aspects
of Christian revelation in such a way as to answer satisfactorily the theological problems
of his time.
The central axis of his living theology is his deep investigation into the meaning of the
personal or hypostatic principle in divine being and in humanity, and his description
of certain features of humanity which determine man's final realization as far as this is possible
within the limits of earthly life.
This theology is presented as an account of man's personal encounter with the living God,
and as a chronicle of the experience of divine light.
St. Syloon and his disciple and biographer Archimandrite Sephroni deserve a place in the history
of the Church.
St. Syloon and Archimandrite Sephroni are a subject worthy of consideration in the academic
circles of contemporary theology.
Their uniqueness of Orthodox anthropology has the last word to say in response to the challenges
and existential problems of our generation.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.
The following works of Father Sephroni have been published in English.
St. Syloon the Athenite, St. Peter's monastery of St. John the Baptist, 1991, Christwood, St.
Vladimir's seminary press, 1999, his life is mine, St. Vladimir's seminary press, 1977.
We shall see him as he is, St. Peter's monastery of St. John the Baptist, 1988.
On prayer, St. Peter's monastery of St. John the Baptist, 1996, Christwood, St. Vladimir's
seminary press, 1998.
Words of life, St. Peter's monastery of St. John the Baptist, 1988, Principles of Orthodox
monasticism in the Orthodox Ethos, extracts from St. Syloon the Athenite are published
as The Monk of Mount Athos, St. Ed's Syloon, 1866 through 1938, St. Vladimir's seminary
press, 1975, wisdom from Mount Athos, writings of St. Syloon.